Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你只能随便报个假名，比如你的咖啡馆名，茱莉亚。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等一下。茱莉亚到底喜欢哪种意式浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 的意式浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些纠结了，因为你在家里就能自己做。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. The page of future history will tell how Britain planted, nourished, and for two centuries preserved a second British Empire. How strengthened by her sons, she rose to such a pitch of power that this little island proved too mighty for the greatest efforts of the greatest nations. Within the space of 20 years, the world beheld her arms triumphant in every quarter of the globe.
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。未来历史的篇章将讲述，英国是如何播种、滋养并在两个世纪里守护着第二个大英帝国；在子民的强盛下，她又是如何攀上如此权力的巅峰，以至于这个小小岛国证明了自己足以抵御最伟大国家的最强图谋。短短二十年间，世人便目睹她的军队在世界每一个角落凯旋。
Her fleet displayed victorious banners, her sails were spread, and conquest graced the canvas. Historic truth must likewise relate. Within the same little space of time, her Britain fell to half her greatness. How strangely lost, by misjudging ministers, by rash advised councils, our gracious sovereign George III saw more than half his empire crumble beneath his scepter. America, late the strength, now the foe to Britain, dismembered, torn, I fear forever lost to England, whence she sprung. So Tom, that was the Duke of Manchester in November 1775 in a House of Lords debate about using foreign troops in the colonies in the American War of Independence. So this is, for us in Britain, the funny thing about this is we don't
她的舰队展示着胜利的旗帜，帆影远扬，征服的身影点缀着风帆。历史的真相同样必须记载。就在这同一小段时期内，大英却跌落至其伟大辉煌的一半。由于误判时局的大臣、由于仓促轻率的谋划，我们的仁慈君主乔治三世眼睁睁看着他半数以上的帝国在权杖下崩解。美国，昔日英国的力量，如今却成了英国的敌人——被肢解、被撕裂，我担心她将永远离英国而去，而她本是从这里发源的。所以，汤姆，那是1775年11月曼彻斯特公爵在英国上议院辩论中说的话，当时讨论的是在独立战争中是否要在殖民地使用外国军队。所以对我们英国人来说，有趣的地方在于，我们其实
really know much about this at all, do we? it looms so large in the consciousness of americans but it's not taught in britain it doesn't really have any great purchase on our national imagination it's weird isn't it how um in britain we don't really know very much about wars that we lose no but we that's for the funny thing is i knew you were going to say that but i thought to myself myself, we actually love defeats. So Gordon, Khartoum. Yes, but they're heroic. Heroic defeats. Right, exactly. And heroic defeats in which ultimately we prevail.
对这些事情其实并不太了解，对吧？它在美国人的意识中占据了如此重要的地位，但在英国却没有被教授，它在我们的国家想象中其实并没有占据多大的分量。这不是很奇怪吗？嗯……在英国，我们其实对我们打输的战争并不太了解。不，不过我们……这就是有趣的地方，我知道你要这么说，但我心里想的是，我们其实热爱失败。比如戈登、喀土穆。对，但那些是英雄式的。英雄式的失败。没错，确实如此。而且是最终我们能够获胜的英雄式失败。
Maybe, maybe, maybe you're right. So, you know, and the Duke of Manchester's comment there. Yeah. That I fear forever lost to England. I mean, he wasn't wrong. Very tragic. Yes. So the American Revolution, an enormous um uh one in which many of our
也许，也许，也许你是对的。所以，你知道的，曼彻斯特公爵刚才的评论……是的。我担心她将永远离英国而去。我的意思是，他并没有说错。非常悲惨。是的。所以，美国革命，这是一场巨大的……嗯……许多我们的
listeners will have strong opinions i think it's fair to say tom certainly those who live in america although the funny as we said the funny thing is that our british listeners probably won't have strong opinions because they don't really know anything about it and we're going to cover it in the next two weeks in a mighty epic and we have recruited a mighty expert have we not we have um and uh this expert like ourselves is uh british yeah so i'm sure all our american listeners will be thrilled to get the perspective from the mother country it's important that the podcast is not polluted by any bias which is why we didn't have an American. And Tom, we welcome back to the podcast Professor Adam Smith, who is the Edward Osborne Professor of History at Oxford. That's right, isn't it, Adam? And director of the Rothermere American Institute.
听众都会有强烈的看法，我想这么说很公平，汤姆，尤其是那些住在美洲的人。尽管正如我们所说，有趣的是，我们的英国听众可能不会有什么强烈的看法，因为他们对这事其实一无所知。我们将在接下来的两周里，以一场宏大的史诗级节目来讲述这段历史，而且我们还招募了一位重量级的专家，不是吗？我们确实请到了……而且，嗯……这位专家和我们一样，也是英国人。所以，我确信我们所有的美国听众都会很高兴能听到来自母国的视角。重要的是，这个播客不能被任何偏见所污染，这也是为什么我们没有找一个美国人。汤姆，我们欢迎亚当·史密斯教授重返我们的播客，他是牛津大学的爱德华·奥斯本历史学教授。没错吧，亚当？他还是罗瑟米尔美国研究所的主任。
That's right, Dom. Yes, it's good to be back. So, Adam, a massive subject, a tragic subject, some might say. And maybe we should start, since this is such a black hole in the British imagination, by giving a picture of the colonies. So we are in, well, we're not quite yet in the 1770s, are we? Because we're going to do the sort of, we need to paint a picture before we really get stuck in. So we did a podcast a few weeks ago with Malcolm Gaskell about witches in New England, and that was in the late 17th century. But a century on, where are we? What do the colonies look like? They look very prosperous, very confident, very populous.
没错，多姆。是的，很高兴能回来。那么，亚当，这是一个宏大的主题，有人甚至会说是一个悲剧的主题。也许我们应该先描绘一下殖民地的面貌，既然这段历史在英国人的认知中是个巨大的黑洞。所以我们正处于……嗯，其实还没到1770年代，对吧？因为我们要先做一些铺垫，在我们真正深入探讨之前，我们需要先勾勒出一幅图景。所以我们几周前和马尔科姆·加斯克尔做了一期关于新英格兰女巫的播客，那是17世纪末的事。但一个世纪之后，我们身处何方？殖民地是什么样子的？它们看起来非常繁荣、非常自信、人口非常稠密。
The Royal Navy calculated that the population of the colonies were two inches taller than the population of England. And that tells you a lot, doesn't it, in the 1750s and 1760s. About one and a half million people lived in the colonies, the 13 colonies that were to go on to rebel. And they were used to self-government in practice. And this is obviously really important in terms of the story that we're going to tell. They had different kinds of charters. Some were royal colonies, some were established in different ways. But in one way or another, they all had forms of representative government. And because property was much more easily accessible, they all had property qualifications, a property franchise, just as was the case in Great Britain. But in practice, this meant that a much wider number of
英国皇家海军计算过，殖民地居民的身价比英国本土居民高出两英寸。在1750年代和1760年代，这说明了很多问题，不是吗？大约有一百五十万人生活在殖民地，即后来起诉反叛的十三块殖民地。他们习惯了实际上的自治。就我们接下来要讲述的故事而言，这显然非常重要。他们拥有不同种类的特许状。有些是皇家殖民地，有些是以不同方式建立的。但不管怎样，他们都拥有某种形式的代议制政府。而且由于土地更容易获得，他们都设有财产资格限制，拥有财产选举权，就像在大不列颠本土那样。但在实践中，这意味着有更多得多的
people could vote and participate in government. In New England, they had this very strongly entrenched tradition of town meetings. And so there was this really active participation in the formulation of policy and the running of local affairs. And so London seemed a very long way away. In another sense, London seemed closer perhaps than the other colonies. It was much easier to get from Boston to London than it was from Boston to Charlestown in South Carolina. There was a post road from Boston to New York, but it was a trial to get from Boston to Philadelphia. So there wasn't much intercolonial interaction. But nevertheless,
人能够投票并参与政府管理。在新英格兰，他们有着根深蒂固的镇民大会传统。因此，在政策的制定和地方事务的管理上，有着非常积极的参与。所以，伦敦当时看起来非常遥远。从另一个意义上说，伦敦有时似乎比其他殖民地还要近。从波士顿到伦敦，比从波士顿到南卡罗来纳的查尔斯顿要容易得多。从波士顿到纽约有一条邮驿大道，但从波士顿去费城简直是一场煎熬。因此，殖民地之间并没有太多的互动。然而，
they were separate from the mother country in terms of practical governance. That didn't mean they felt separate, though. They were patriotic Englishmen and they said that repeatedly right up until the the breach in 1776. So Adam what what is the British kind of governmental presence in the new world? Well it's very slight Tom but the the the seven years war which I know you've also done a podcast about haven't you so I don't know whether we want to get into that now. But the Seven Years' War really changed the dynamic because then there was a British military presence. There was a distant London supervision of the colonies.
就实际治理而言，他们与母国是分离的。但这并不意味着他们觉得自己在情感上是分离的。他们是爱国英国人，直到1776年决裂之前，他们一直在反复重申这一点。那么，亚当，英国人在新世界到底有什么样的政府存在呢？嗯，非常微弱，汤姆，但是……七年战争——我知道你之前也做过关于它的播客，不是吗？所以我不知道我们现在是否想深入探讨这个。但七年战争真正改变了这种动态，因为从那时起，英国有了军事存在。伦敦开始对殖民地进行遥远的监督。
There was a Secretary of State for America. And there was a complex system of navigation laws, the McCantillist system, which attempted to restrict colonial trade, although it wasn't very good at doing so. It was an incredibly leaky system. So there was a broad framework of law within the context of Britain and the allegiance to the British royal family, which Englishmen on the other side of the Atlantic always felt. But the Seven Years' War was the moment when presence was felt on the ground, I think. And so the Seven Years' War in America is generally known as the French and Indian War. Is that right? That's right, yes. And that kind of sums up what the stakes are for Britain and for the 13 colonies in North America,
设立了美洲事务国务秘书。并且存在一套复杂的航海法体系，即重商主义体系，它试图限制殖民地贸易，尽管它的实际效果并不好。这是一个漏洞百出的系统。因此，在英国的框架以及对英国王室效忠的背景下，大西洋彼岸的英国人始终能感受到广泛的法律框架。但我认为，七年战争正是这种存在感在实地显现的时刻。那么，七年战争在美洲通常被称为法国与印第安人战争。是这样吗？是的，没错。这在某种程度上概括了英国以及北美十三块殖民地在这场战争中的利害关系，
because they are faced with two foes. They're faced with the French, which have a massive imperial presence in Canada and kind of reaching into the center of North America. And of course, they have the Indians, as they were called, the Native Americans, who are also very, very kind of sizable confederations at this point. And yet the British emerge victorious from that war. The French are basically expelled from the New World. And the corollary of that is that there is a huge military presence now in America. And that presumably is something that hadn't been the case prior to the Seven Years' War. Exactly. This is really, this whole story over all these
因为他们面临着两个敌人。他们面临着法国人，法国人在加拿大拥有庞大的帝国势力，并且正在向北美腹地延伸；当然，他们还面临着印第安人——当时人们是这么称呼他们的，即美洲原住民——在这个时候，他们也是规模非常非常庞大的部落联盟。然而，英国人却从那场战争中取得了胜利。法国人基本上被逐出了新世界。而随之而来的结果是，如今在美洲有了庞大的军事存在。想必这在七年战争之前是不曾有的情况吧？确切地说。实际上，所有这些关于美国革命的剧集，
episodes of doing the American Revolution is really a story about the French. It's a story about British relations with Europe in one sense. And, you know, you ask about British presence in America. If you're a British administrator in Whitehall, thinking about your colonies in the middle of the 18th century, you're not really worried about what's going to happen in the port cities in Boston and Philadelphia before the 1860s. What you're worried about, as you say, Tom, is the French presence in the interior and the question of the balance of power in Europe and how the European presence in North America might affect that. Is it not also the case, Adam, that when people talk about the colonies, they're really talking about, I mean, if you were to say to somebody in 1740,
整个故事其实都是关于法国人的。从某种意义上说，这是一个关于英国与欧洲关系的故事。而且，你问到英国在美洲的存在感。如果你是白厅的一名英国行政官员，在18世纪中期考虑你的殖民地时，你在1860年代之前，其实并不怎么担心波士顿和费城港口城市会发生什么。正如你所说，汤姆，你真正担心的是法国在内地的存在，以及欧洲在北美的力量平衡问题，以及这可能会如何影响欧洲的局势。亚当，难道不是吗？当人们谈论殖民地时，他们真正谈论的——也就是说，如果你在1740年对某人说，
I'm going out to the colonies, I'm very worried about the colonies. You're talking about Barbados, Jamaica. The incredibly lucrative islands of the Caribbean rather than, are they backwaters? Is that too strong to describe the colonies? It's too strong because in population terms, they were so much more populous. But that's absolutely right.
我要去殖民地了，我对殖民地非常担心。你其实是在说巴巴多斯、牙买加。加勒比海那些极其利润丰厚的岛屿，而不是……它们是偏远落后地区吗？用“偏远”来形容殖民地会不会太过了？这确实有点过分，因为从人口角度来看，它们的人口要多得多。但你的说法完全正确。
There were 26 British colonies in the New World in the middle of the 18th century. Only half of them rebelled in what we call the American Revolution. And we'll get onto this later. But in one sense, the American War of Independence was not by any means a complete disaster for the British because what they managed to stave off was the much more worrying prospect of losing the Sugar Islands, Jamaica, Barbados, Antigua, which they avoided, not without having to fight naval battles
在18世纪中叶，新世界一共有26个英国殖民地。其中只有一半在我们所称的美国革命中叛乱了。我们稍后会讨论这一点。但从某种意义上说，对英国人来说，美国独立战争绝不是一场彻底的灾难，因为他们成功避开了更令人担忧的前景——失去糖岛（牙买加、巴巴多斯、安提瓜）。他们避免了这一结局，当然，这也少不了与法国和西班牙进行海战。所以，亚当，有一个惊人的统计数据：北美本土最大的农作物是烟草，平均每年销售额为75万英镑；但西印度群岛的甘蔗、糖蜜、朗姆酒以及其他所有东西的年平均收益却将近400万英镑。没错。所以这给人们留下了一个非常深刻的印象，即利益攸关。不过，再次回到北美与法国及美洲原住民的战略形势上，1755年发生了一次关键的远征，不是吗？由布拉多克将军率领，他试图突袭并攻占法军在现今匹兹堡的迪凯恩堡。而这次行动以惨败告终。布拉多克战死。这是英国历史上最大的军事惨败之一。但其中引人入胜的是，有两个来自北美殖民地的人卷入了其中：一个是名叫乔治·华盛顿的年轻军官，他非常渴望获得英国陆军的委任状，并在布拉多克将军麾下担任副官；另一个是费城的一个名叫本杰明·富兰克林的男子，他提供了大约150辆马车。
against the French and the Spanish. So Adam, an amazing stat that the mainland North America's largest crop is tobacco, and that sells for an average of £750,000 a year. But the sugar cane and the molasses and the rum and everything from the West Indies is fetching an annual average of nearly £4 million. Right. So that gives a really impressive sense of what's at stake. But again, just to go back to the strategic situation in North America with the French and the Native Americans, there's a key expedition, isn't there, in 1755 led by General Braddock, who is striking out to try and capture a French fort, Duquesne, in what's now Pittsburgh. And this ends disastrously. Braddock ends up dead. It's one of the great military defeats in British history. But the thing that's intriguing about it is the involvement of two people from the North American colonies, one of them a young officer called George Washington, who is very keen to get a commission with the British Army and kind of serves as an aide-de-camp to General Braddock. And the other one is a man in Philadelphia called Benjamin Franklin, who furnishes, I think, 150 wagons.
这两个人，你知道的，这些年轻人当时都非常非常爱国，非常非常亲英。是的。而且在两人身上，尤其是华盛顿身上，他们也都非常渴望在俄亥俄河谷获得土地。这正是这一切背后的很大一部分驱动力。关于法国人可能与美洲原住民部落结盟的担忧是什么？以及与土著居民不断变动的关系又意味着什么？那种持续的感受是，在俄亥俄河谷内陆，有着巨大的财富。乔治·华盛顿本人对此投入极深。他既是一个测量员，也是一名军官，嗯……尽管他来自一个非常富有的弗吉尼亚家庭，而且他娶了弗吉尼亚最富有的寡妇，但他最终还是像18世纪的
And both of those, you know, these young men at that time are very, very patriotic, very, very pro-British. Yes. And in both cases, and especially in Washington's case, also very keen on the acquisition of land in the Ohio Valley. And that's what's driving a lot of this. What is the concern about potential French alliances with Native American tribes and the constantly shifting relations with indigenous people. It's that there is this constant sense that there is huge wealth out there inland in the Ohio Valley. And George Washington is personally really invested in that. He's a surveyor as well as a officer um he although he's from a very wealthy virginia family and he marries the richest widow in virginia he still ends up as 18th century
绅士们经常做的那样，负债累累，并且渴望、渴望获得更多的土地。所以他，就像成千上万的其他美洲殖民者一样，对阿巴拉契亚山脉以西的白人欧洲殖民扩张有着非常个人化的财务投资。这是这个故事的关键。关于土地压力的那个问题，殖民地居民向内陆推进，甚至在七年战争之前，是不是有一种感觉：英国，即所谓的“宗主国”，正试图阻止他们这样做？这其中是否存在某种紧张关系？还是说这直到七年战争结束时才出现？多米尼克，我不认为在七年战争之前宗主国有能力去尝试这样做，但他们在七年战争的背景下变得极其意识到这一点，
gentlemen often did hugely indebted and and and wants and wants more land so he like like hundreds and thousands of other american colonists has a have a very personal financial investment in white European expansion beyond the Appalachians. And that's key to this story. That issue about the pressure for land, the colonists pushing in land, even before the Seven Years' War, is there a sense that the British, the metropole, as it were, that they're trying to restrain them from doing that? Is there a sort of tension there? Or does that not come in until the end of the Seven Years' War? I don't think the metropole before the Seven Years' War really has the capacity to try to do that, Dominic, but they become extremely conscious of it in the context of the Seven
因为那是他们不得不花费代价的时候——英国政府不得不花费巨额资金来处理西部土地争夺战所带来的后果。但是，亚当，七年战争的一个悖论式后果，难道不是它实际上在美洲的英国国王臣民与英国本土臣民之间制造了难以置信的紧张关系吗？因为英国政府和美洲殖民者得出了截然不同的结论。英国政府的结论是：为了北美大英帝国的稳定，绝对有必要让美洲原住民站在他们这边，让他们乐于与英国结盟；而像乔治·华盛顿这样的美国人则认为，教训应该是我们应该全力争取，我们应该跨过阿巴拉契亚山脉。我们应该在超越那里的富饶土地上定居。这其中存在一种内在的利益冲突，随着年份甚至几十年过去，这种冲突将变得越来越两极分化。是的，完全正确，汤姆。1763年的《公告线》就是英国政府的努力，至少是暂时的努力。（我的意思是，他们在美洲革命之前后来把这条线向西推得更远了）。但这代表了他们试图划定“此地止步，绝不越雷池一步”的底线。而且他们也知道，监督这条线的唯一方法就是在北美保留英国正规军，而这就成了冲突的根源，因为这些军队需要军费开支。是的，所以我正在看
Years' War, because that's when they have to spend, the British government has to spend an extraordinary amount of money in dealing with the consequences of the fight over land in the West. But Adam, isn't one of the kind of the paradoxical consequences of the Seven Years' War that it actually generates incredible tensions between British subjects of the crown in America and those in Britain, because the British government and the American colonials draw entirely separate conclusions. The British government's conclusion is that it's absolutely essential for the stability of the British Empire in North America, that Native Americans be kept on board, that they stay happy to be in alliance with Britain. Whereas Americans like George Washington think the lesson is we should go for
统计数据——1763年正是发布公告的那一年，所以1763年也是七年战争的最后一年，如果我没记错的话。是的，这也是庞蒂亚克起义爆发的那一年。是的。所以那是一场印第安人的……我的意思是，“起义”这个词或许不太准确，因为它暗示了一种形式上的从属关系。但有一个叫庞蒂亚克的家伙领导了一群美洲原住民。他们进入了宾夕法尼亚、马里兰和弗吉尼亚，杀了两千人。那是他们在一场长曲棍球比赛中发生的那次事件吗？他们把球扔进堡垒里，然后假装去把球捡回来，
this, we should cross the Appalachians. We should settle these very, very rich lands that lie beyond. And there's a kind of inherent conflict of interests there that will get more and more polarizing as the years and then the decades go past. Yes, that's exactly right, Tom. And the proclamation line of 1763 is the British government's efforts, at least temporarily. I mean, they later pushed the line further westwards, I mean, before the American Revolution. But it's their attempt to say this far and no further. And they also know that the only way to police that line is to retain british regular troops in north america and that then becomes the source of conflict as well because they need to be paid for yeah so i'm just looking at the
接着大开杀戒，是这样吗？我对长曲棍球的了解非常粗浅。这是一个顶级的与体育有关的大屠杀，对吧？但我只是在看这些数字：英国在当时（1763年）的债务是1.37亿英镑，利息——也就是战争债务及其利息——光是这笔债务的利息就高达每年500万英镑。而在战争爆发前，英国每年的和平时期预算是每年800万英镑。所以可以想象，那种“噢，殖民者会不断向前推进、不断推进、不断推进，而我们需要军队来阻止他们这样做，或者在他们真的这样做时去处理美洲原住民不可避免的骚乱”的问题，在一个体量很小的国家世界里，这对英国政府来说一定是个绝对……
stats so 1763 which is when the proclamation is made so 1763 is also it's the final year of the seven years war i think i'm right in saying yeah it's also the year of Pontiac's Rebellion. Yeah. So that's an Indian, I mean, uprising is perhaps not the right word because it implies sort of formal subordination. But there's a guy called Pontiac leads a group of Native Americans. They go into Pennsylvania, Maryland, Virginia. They kill 2,000 people. Is that the one where they're playing a lacrosse match? And they chuck a ball into a fort and then pretend to go and get the ball back and
是的。这种想法——把所有这些钱仅仅花掉并扔进水里——简直是无法容忍的。这绝对是一场危机。我的意思是，七年战争是……英国在七年战争中的胜利是一场辉煌且不可思议的胜利。它在整个英格兰都受到了热烈的庆祝。当然，这是一场世界范围内的战争，不仅局限于北美。但它随之而来的是极其巨大的和平治理问题。财政负担才是真正让人吃力的地方。
then massacre everyone is that right my knowledge of lacrosse is very sketchy it's a top sports related massacre right but i'm just looking at the figures so britain's debt at that point 1763 is 137 million pounds and the inch so that's the war debt and the interest alone on that debt is five million pounds a year and before the war britain's annual peacetime budget had been eight million pounds a year so presumably that issue of oh the colonists are going to keep pushing keep pushing keep pushing and we need troops either to stop them from doing so or to deal with the inevitable ructions among the native Americans when they do do it, that must be absolute for British governments in a very small state world.
维持治安的困难——当然，我们甚至还没有讨论魁北克的问题，以及魁北克现在已经成为大英帝国一部分的天主教法国人口。英国政府如何试图将这些人也纳入大英帝国的问题，这也是故事的一部分。所以可怜的白厅行政官员们不得不应对这个问题，七年战争结束后上台的新政府也面临着一堆巨大的难题。当然，他们并不是从十三块殖民地的视角来看待这一切的。我的意思是，他们根本不知道接下来二十年会发生什么。
Yeah. That's intolerable, presumably, the idea of spending all that money just and throwing money away. It's a complete crisis. I mean, the Seven Years' War is... The British victory in the Seven Years' War is a glorious and incredible victory. And it's much celebrated across England. And, of course, it's a war fought all around the world, not just in North America. But it brings with it the problems of peace are immense. And the financial burdens are where it really hits.
他们当中没有人去过那里。美国人倒是会来拜访。你知道的，本·富兰克林总是跑过来，展示他的智慧，散播他的高见。但是，你知道的，他们正试图用一个非常脆弱的税收基础来管理这个庞大、复杂的世界帝国。英国人民已经承受了沉重的税负，是欧洲纳税最多的人。试图维持这个帝国的运转存在着各种各样的压力。他们最不需要的就是十三块殖民地的白人殖民者带来的连续不断麻烦，而他们认为这些殖民者无论如何都已经得到了他们想要的一切。他们的税收负担很轻。
The difficulties of maintaining – of course, we haven't even got into the question of Quebec as well, and the Catholic French population in Quebec, which has now become part of the British Empire. And the question of how the British government tries to bring those people into the British Empire as well is also part of the story. So the poor administrators in Whitehall having to deal with this problem, and the new government that comes in after the end of the Seven Years' War has a huge set of difficulties. And they're not looking at this, of course, from the perspective of the 13 colonies. I mean, they don't know what's going to happen over the next 20 years.
他们拥有大量廉价土地。他们为什么还需要俄亥俄河谷的更多东西呢？从1763年的白厅视角来看，这完全是一套可以理解的假设。白厅以及伦敦的人们——所以我们刚才，你知道的，你还在拿本杰明·富兰克林的民间智慧开玩笑……我是不是有种印象，难道他不是在谈论试管之类的东西吗？我的意思是，那难道不是他的科学领域吗？汤姆，他是不是跟科学有什么关系？闪电，对，避雷针。他在谈论避雷针。
None of them have ever been there. Americans visit. You know, Ben Franklin's always coming over and, you know, giving his, dispensing his wisdom. But, you know, they're trying to run this huge, complex world empire with a very shaky tax base. The British people are hugely taxed, the most taxed in Europe. There's all kinds of strains in trying to run this empire. And the last thing they need are continual trouble from their white colonists in the 13 colonies, who they think, well, they've got everything they want anyway. They're very undertaxed.
我知道人们很喜欢这一点。但当人们想到美国人时，他们通常会怎么想？我想他们在接触美国人时，确实觉得他们与众不同。我的意思是，至少新英格兰人的口音听起来就不一样。有关于美国人说话方式的语音记录，英国人显然觉得这非常滑稽。显然，已经传了好几代人了。我的意思是，你知道的，从这些殖民地的最初建立到我们所谈论的时代，中间有150年的时间。所以这些都是历史悠久的定居点，它们的发展方式与宗主国有着相当大的差异。亚当，像乔治·华盛顿这样的人。乔治·华盛顿，当然，他甚至没有自己的牙齿。乔治·华盛顿的口音，如果他现在跟我们说话，会是什么听起来的样子？为什么HBO或任何制作公司的人会认为乔治·华盛顿的口音是那个样子的？我的意思是，我喜欢他确实是那样的想法。当然，他还有木制的牙齿，不是吗？毫无疑问，这也会对他的发音造成影响。所以如果美洲的人们……
They've got lots of cheap land. What do they need more in the Ohio River Valley for? And that's and that's an entirely understandable set of assumptions i think viewed from whitehall in 1763 what people in whitehall and indeed in london so we were just you know you were joking about benjamin franklin's folksy wisdom um is i i was under the impression he was is he not talking about test tubes and things like that i mean is that not his is science? Tom, is he something to do with science? Lightning, yeah, lightning conductors. He's talking about lightning rods.
我是说，他们的口音在许多英国人听来……算是某种程度上可以辨认的，对吧？就像是英国口音。英国人是如何看待美国人的？他们是将他们基本上视为英国人，还是或许将他们视为……嗯……17th世纪的遗老，那种来自英国过去的人，但有点像是活化石，如果你愿意这么说的话。我想是这样的。但这实际上指出了你刚才所说的那句话中重要的一点，汤姆，那就是我不确定英国人是否真的会把13个殖民地的美国人
I know that people enjoy that. But what do people generally think when they think about Americans? I think they do think of them as different when they encounter them. I mean, the New Englanders at least sounded different. I mean, they had Yankee accents. There are phonetic reports of the way that Americans spoke, which clearly British people found deeply amusing. And obviously, there'd been many, many generations. I mean, you know, there's 150 years between the first
都看作是同一类人。所以我想他们看待南部种植园主——南卡罗来纳人和弗吉尼亚人——的方式，可能和他们看待加勒比海种植园主的方式差不多。而至于新英格兰人，他们只会把他们看作是……你知道的，那些克伦威尔式的、毫无幽默感的清教徒类型的后代，并会以相当不同的眼光来看待他们。因为我的意思是，理解殖民地正在发生的事情至关重要的一点是，他们的宗教信仰其实也非常不同。所以你拥有……
settlement of these colonies and the time we're talking about. So these are long established places that have grown in ways that are quite different from the metropole. So somebody like George Washington, Adam. George Washington, of course, doesn't even have his own teeth. George Washington, his accent, what would he have sounded like if he was talking to us now? Why does anybody from HBO or whoever it is think that George Washington sounds like that? I mean, I love the idea that he did. He had wooden teeth, of course, as well, wouldn wouldn't he which would no doubt also have impeded it so if um people in america are
你拥有新英格兰的清教徒长老会建制，而你在费城这个“兄弟之爱之城”则有贵格会。是的，而且……其他殖民地有着更多盎格鲁-撒克逊（英国国教）的色彩。是的。在弗吉尼亚，有建立的英国国教教会，有着截然不同的宗教氛围。殖民地居民自己也在不断地谈论这一点。我的意思是，乔治·华盛顿在去波士顿接管大陆军之前，从来没有去过新英格兰。我的意思是，他为什么要去做那种事呢？他去过加勒比海，这正好说明了南方种植园主和糖岛之间有着相似的利益和价值观。但他把新英格兰人看作是一群奇怪、肮脏的乌合之众，有着奇怪的宗教信仰，对他来说非常陌生。但是，亚当，我们还没有讨论的一点，绝对是至关重要的，那就是大觉醒运动（The Great Awakening）？所以这场运动在18世纪早期席卷了殖民地，大约是18世纪早期到中期，这种福音派的热情，人们举行这些集会并谈论上帝。
i mean their accents are kind of recognizable yes as kind of being british to many people in britain how are people in britain viewing americans are they seeing them as basically british people or as perhaps as as um as relics from the 17th century, kind of people who are from the past of Britain, but kind of living fossils, if you like. I think that's right. But that actually points to something important in what you just said there, Tom, which is I'm not sure really that people in Britain would have seen Americans
这绝对对殖民地的生活产生了巨大的影响，不是吗？确实如此。它在英国也发生了。而且有许多相同的传教士，乔治·怀特菲尔德（George Whitefield）就是最著名的一个，他在1739年乘船前往美洲，在此之前他在牛津大学彭布罗克学院时皈依了福音派宗教，这后来也发生在好几个人身上。嘿，亚当，我们认识这样的人，不是吗？我们确实认识。他在牛津时是某个组织成员，他曾是被称为“神圣俱乐部”（Holy Club）的成员。无论如何，他去了……乔治·怀特菲尔德是一位非凡的公众演讲者。
in the 13 colonies all in the same way. So I think they would have seen the southern planters, the South Carolinians and the Virginians, and perhaps in much the same way as they saw the planters of the Caribbean. Whereas the New Englanders, they just would have seen as, you know, the descendants of the Cromwellian, humorless Puritan types, and would have seen them in quite a different light. Because I mean mean it's a it's crucial isn't it to understanding what's happening in the colonies that they're actually very different religious dispensations as well so you've got um you've got the kind of the the
事实上，本杰明·富兰克林——正如你所说，多米尼克，他是一位科学家——在去听乔治·怀特菲尔德演讲时做了所有这些实验。他其实对乔治·怀特菲尔德在说什么并不感兴趣，但他对乔治·怀特菲尔德是如何投射声音的、他的声音能传多远以及有多少人能听到感兴趣。所以他做了所有这些计算，关于在同一时刻有多少人能听到乔治·怀特菲尔德的声音。但正如你所说，殖民地被这种宗教狂热所席卷，虽然并非均匀分布，新英格兰的程度肯定比其他地方更深。多年来，历史学家们试图将大觉醒运动与美国革命的到来联系起来——并非完全牵强——其理由是，福音派关注的是个人，是对正式权威的不信任，是与上帝的直接关系，是掌控自己的生活。如果没有大觉醒运动，美国革命会发生吗？可能会，但它看起来可能会有些不同。好吧，很显然，英国和殖民者之间的关系正在破裂。所以我想我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，再来看看发生了什么。但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 的意式浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些纠结了，因为你在家里就能自己做。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
puritan presbyterian establishment in new england and you've got the quakers in philadelphia the city of brotherly love yes and um it's kind of much more Anglican tinge to other colonies. Yeah. With established churches in Virginia, there was an Anglican Church of England establishment, a quite different religious feel. And the colonists themselves were constantly talking about this. I mean, George Washington had never been to New England before he went to Boston to take command of the Continental Army. I mean, why would he have done? He'd been to New England before he went to Boston to take command of the Continental Army. I mean, why would he have done? He'd been to the Caribbean, which sort of makes this point about the similar interests and values of the southern planters
我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在探讨美国独立战争、革命战争，随便你想怎么称呼它。我们请来了伟大的亚当·史密斯来为我们梳理这些复杂的议题。顺着刚才提到的“各个殖民地存在不同的宗教建制”这一思路。我的意思是，这难道不也会对各个殖民者、各自的殖民地居民如何理解政府的功能产生影响吗？因为在新英格兰的整个那一套，清教徒的理念是……你在南方的那些更具英国国教色彩的州。同样，他们对于政府应该如何运作、什么是理想的政府形式，会有不同的理解。是的，我的确是这么看的，汤姆。并不是说十三块殖民地的居民不喜欢自治和独立。他们喜欢。问题在于这意味着什么。直到1775年，他们相信自己可以在大英帝国之内实现自治、独立、有效地管理他们自己的贸易并自行纳税。最终让他们觉得这一切变得不可能的，是英国政府的行动。所以，在1763年，我们在这里谈论的一切——
and the Sugar Islands. But he saw these New Englanders as just this kind of weird, dirty rabble with this strange religion and very alien to him. But one thing we haven't yet talked about, Adam, which is massive, surely, is the Great Awakening. So that sweeps across the colonies in the early part of the 18th, sort of early to mid-18th century, this sort of evangelical enthusiasm, people having these meetings and talking about God.
这些试图在殖民地筹集税收的尝试，仅仅是为了支付实际上部署在边境上的常备军的费用，并打击当时猖獗的走私活动，打击对《航海条例》（即规范大英帝国贸易规则的法规）的逃避。这种试图使大英帝国治理专业化和现代化的尝试——首相乔治·格兰维尔（George Grenville）从他的角度出发，在1763年非常明智地开始尝试这样做——终结了此前看似漫长的来自伦敦的“良性忽视”时期。这就是变化所在。这就是行动的来源。
And that surely has a massive impact on life in the colonies, doesn't it? It does. And it takes place in Great Britain as well. And with many of the same preachers, George Whitefield being the most famous who sailed to the Americas in 1739, having been turned to evangelical religion while he was at Pembroke College, Oxford, something that's happened to several people since then. Hey, we know someone like that, Adam, don't we? We do. He was a member of something when he was at Oxford, he was a member of something called the Holy Club. Anyway, he went to, George Whitefield was an extraordinary public speaker.
那些人在伦敦采取了行动。所以，亚当——我知道我们的许多听众会认为这很不公平——但你能不能合理地说，其实这里发生的事情是：英国政府终于开始着手解决这个棘手的问题了。他们容忍了一个非常混乱的系统持续了数十年，里面充斥着大量的走私和各种烂事；最后，以一种非常开明的方式，他们说：“好啦，让我们把这清理干净。让我们走上正轨，为殖民地提供适当的防务，进行适当的组织，按时纳税。”你知道的，这并不是什么暴政，这也不是什么新鲜事。我知道人们会觉得这不公平，而且是在偏袒英国，但这其实是一种相当合理的说法，不是吗？我相信会有听众觉得这是一种非常不公平的说法，多米尼克，但我认为这是完全合理的。而且……你刚才没有提到的一点是威斯敏斯特议会的作用，因为我提到了首相格兰维尔。这是伦敦的英国政府通过议会采取行动。当然，英国的每个人都理解这一点，但似乎殖民地的大多数人并不完全理解这一点，那就是“光荣革命”。如你所知，这场革命确立了议会主权原则，即“国王在议会中”这一模糊但重要的理念。因此，我们在英国这一边谈论的所有这些人——其中有些人被称为托利党人，但他们所有人在广义上都是辉格党人，因为他们都支持1689年结算、支持光荣革命。
In fact, Benjamin Franklin, who, as you say, Dominic, was a scientist, did all these experiments when he went to listen to George Whitefield. He wasn't really interested in what George Whitefield was saying, but he was interested in how George Whitefield projected his voice and how far he could project and how many people. So he did all these calculations about how many people could hear George Whitefield at a single moment. But as you say, the colonies were swept by this religious fervor, not evenly and certainly more in New England than elsewhere. And historians over the years have tried to connect, not wholly and plausibly, the Great Awakening with the coming of the American Revolution on the grounds that evangelicalism is about the individual, it's about distrust of formal authority, about a direct relationship
因此，对他们来说，议会的至高无上是不可谈判的。但有一种看法，不是吗？事实上，美洲殖民者通过反对这种议会理想——这是一个来之不易的理想——实际上是在扮演保王党人的角色。我的意思是，英国有人称……英国有人称美洲殖民者为保王党人。是的，好吧，我的意思是，确实如此。我的意思是，殖民者是这个词真正意义上的托利党人。我的意思是，他们在1775年之前的不同时间点上，直接向国王请愿，要求国王采取违宪行动，推翻议会——就像斯图亚特王朝的国王们曾经做过的那样，而乔治三世却从未准备这样做。尽管当然，从长远来看，美国革命者的战略是宣称乔治三世实际上是个暴君。这非常……但这种把焦点对准乔治三世的策略，汤姆，是直到非常、非常晚的时候才发生的事。那是《独立宣言》以及1776年临近时采取的策略。向他请愿，要求他倾听他们的苦难，尽管乔治三世由于是一位爱国国王并且信仰光荣革命的成果，当然是通过议会在合宪地运作。因此他无法做殖民地居民希望他做的事。所以，为了强调这一点：当你阅读《独立宣言》时，
with God, about taking control of your own life. Would the American Revolution have happened without the Great Awakening? Probably, but it may well have looked a little bit different. Okay, well, things are clearly breaking down between Britain and the colonists. So I think we should take a break. And when we come back, find out what happens. But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
事实上，当你参观波士顿等地的这些历史遗迹时，那里到处都是关于乔治三世与殖民者的对抗，但这其实并不是这件事情的核心。关键在于议会的权威——这对于英国人来说是如此重要——议会相对于殖民地独立的权威。这才是关键的战役，不是吗？这正是关键所在。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are looking at the American War of Independence, the Revolutionary War, whatever you want to call it. And we have the great Adam Smith with us to talk us through these complex issues. Just following on from this idea that there are
“如果我们的贸易可以被征税，为什么我们的土地不能？为什么我们土地的出产以及我们所拥有或使用的每一样东西都不能？”10世纪60年代开会的波士顿商人们如是说。这是一个基本原则：伦敦的议会——当然，殖民地并没有派遣任何议会议员跨越大西洋——从根本上拒绝议会的权威。直到七年战争及其直接余波之前，虽然他们在理论上也可能拒绝过议会的主权，但在实际操作中，它从未真正产生过影响。
different religious dispensations in the various colonies. I mean, doesn't that actually have implication as well for how the various colonists, the respective colonists, understand how government functions? Because the whole thing in New England, the kind of the Puritan idea is that you, you more kind of Anglican states in the south. Again, they would have a different understanding of how, of what it would mean to be, you know, what the ideal form of government should be. Yeah, that's definitely how I see it, Tom. It's not that the inhabitants of the 13 colonies didn't like self-government and independence. They did. The question was what that meant. Up until 1775, they believed they could have self-government and independence and the regulation of their own trade effectively and could tax themselves all within the British Empire. What made that in the end seem impossible to them were the actions of the British government. And so in 1763, everything we've been talking about here,
各个殖民地存在不同的宗教派别。我的意思是，这难道不也对各个殖民地居民、各自的殖民地居民如何理解政府职能产生影响吗？因为新英格兰的整套体制，那种清教徒的想法是……而南方的安立甘宗（英国国教）州则不同。同样，他们对于政府应该是什么样、理想的政府形式应该是什么，会有不同的理解。是的，汤姆，我绝对是这么看的。并不是说这13个殖民地的居民不喜欢自治和独立。他们喜欢。问题在于这意味着什么。直到1775年，他们还相信自己可以在大英帝国境内实现自治、独立、有效地规范自己的贸易，并且能够自行纳税。最终让他们觉得这不可能做到的是英国政府的行为。因此，在1763年，我们这里一直在谈论的一切，
these attempts to raise revenue in the colonies, just in order to defray the costs of keeping a standing army essentially on the frontier and to crack down on the widespread smuggling that was happening, the avoidance of the Navigation Acts, the rules that regulated trade in the British Empire. This attempt just to professionalize and modernize the governance of the British Empire, which Prime Minister George Grenville started to try to do extremely sensibly from his point of view in 1763, that ended what had seemed to be this long period of benign neglect from London. And that's the change. That's where the action came from.
这些在殖民地筹集税收的企图，本质上只是为了承担在边境维持常备军的费用，并打击当时普遍存在的走私活动，即逃避《航海条例》（规范大英帝国贸易的规则）。这种仅仅试图将大英帝国治理专业化和现代化的尝试——首相乔治·格伦维尔从他个人的角度来看，在1763年非常明智地开始尝试这样做——终结了那段似乎来自伦敦的长期“慈忽视政”（benign neglect）。这就是变化所在。这就是行动的来源。
Those are the people making the moves in London. So Adam, I mean, I know a lot of our listeners will think this is very unfair, but could you reasonably say that actually what's happening here is a British government is finally grasping the nettle. They've allowed a very shambolic system to continue for decades with loads of smuggling, all this stuff. And finally, in a very enlightenment way, they're like, right, let's sort this out. Let's put on an even keel, proper defense for the colonies, proper organization, pay your taxes. You know, it's not anything tyrannical it's not anything new i know people will think this is unfair and taking the british side but that is kind of
那些是在伦敦采取行动的人。所以亚当，我的意思是，我知道我们的很多听众会认为这很不公平，但你是否可以合理地说，这里实际发生的是英国政府终于开始着手解决棘手问题了。他们允许一个非常混乱的系统持续了数十年，有着大量的走私以及所有这些烂事。最后，以一种非常启蒙运动的方式，他们说：“好啦，让我们把这清理一下。让我们走上正轨，为殖民地提供适当的防御，建立适当的组织，纳税。”你知道，这并不是什么暴政，这也不是什么新鲜事。我知道人们会觉得这不公平，而且偏袒英国一方，但那种说法其实是一种……
reasonable way of putting it isn't it i'm sure there will be listeners who will think that's a very unfair way of putting it dominic but i think it's entirely reasonable um and and the the dimension here which you which you you haven mentioned, is the role of Parliament in Westminster, because I mentioned Prime Minister Grenville. It's the British government in London acting through Parliament. And of course, what everybody in Britain understands, but which it seems most people in the colonies don't fully understand, is the Glorious Revolution, which establishes, as you know, the principle of parliamentary sovereignty, this amorphous but important idea of the king in parliament. And so it is all of these people we're talking about on the British side, and some of them become known as Tories, but all of them, broadly speaking, are Whiggish in the sense that they all support the settlement of 1689, of the Glorious Revolution.
一种合理的说法，不是吗？我确信会有听众认为这是一种很不公平的说法，多米尼克，但我认为这完全合理。嗯，而且你没有提到的一点是威斯敏斯特议会的作用，因为我提到了格伦维尔首相。这是通过议会行事的伦敦英国政府。当然，英国的每个人都明白，但殖民地的绝大多数人似乎并没有完全理解的是“光荣革命”，正如你所知，它确立了议会至上的原则，即国王在议会中这一模糊但重要的概念。因此，我们讨论的英国一方的所有这些人，其中有些人被称为托利党人，但广义上讲，他们都是辉格党人，因为他们都支持1689年结算方案，即光荣革命的成果。
And therefore, for them, the supremacy of Parliament is the non-negotiable thing. But there's a sense, isn't there, that actually the American colonists, by opposing this ideal of Parliament, one that's been a very hard one, are actually playing the part of royalists. I mean, there are people in England who call the the part of royalists. I mean, there are people who, in England, who call the American colonists royalists. Yes, well, I mean, rightly so. I mean, the colonists are Tories in the real sense of the word. I mean, they are directly, at various points up until 1775, they're directly petitioning the king to act unconstitutionally, to override parliament in the way that the
因此，对他们来说，议会的至高无上是无可谈判的。但有一种感觉，不是吗？实际上，美洲殖民地居民通过反对这种来之不易的议会理想，实际上是在扮演保皇派的角色。我的意思是，英国有人称……美洲殖民地居民为保皇派。是的，嗯，我的意思是，确实如此。我的意思是，殖民地居民是这个词真正意义上的托利党人。我的意思是，在1775年之前的不同时间点，他们直接向国王请愿，要求国王采取违宪行动，推翻议会，就像……
Stuart kings could have done, but George III was never prepared to do. Even though, of course, in the long run, the strategy of the American revolutionaries is to say that George III is actually the tyrant. It's a very... But that manoeuvre to focus on George III, Tom, is something that only happens at the very, very end. That's the maneuver of the Declaration of Independence and the short run up to it in 1776. petitioning him to listen to their grievances, despite the fact that George III is, because he's a Patriot King and believes in the settlement of the Glorious Revolution, is of course operating constitutionally through Parliament. And so he cannot do what the colonists want him to do. So just to hammer that point home, and when you read the Declaration of Independence,
斯图亚特王朝的国王们可能做过的那样，但乔治三世从未准备这样做。尽管当然，从长远来看，美洲革命者的策略是宣称乔治三世实际上是个暴君。这非常……但是汤姆，把焦点集中在乔治三世身上的这种策略，是直到最后关头才发生的。那是《独立宣言》以及1763年临近时短期的策略。向他请愿，希望他倾听他们的冤屈，尽管乔治三世作为一位“爱国国王”并信仰光荣革命的成果，当然是通过议会按宪法行事的。因此，他不能做殖民地居民希望他做的事。所以，为了强调这一点，当你阅读《独立宣言》时，
indeed, when you go around these places in Boston and stuff, and it's all about the George III versus the colonists, that's actually not really what this is about. The key to it is the authority of parliament, which for British people is so important, the authority of parliament vis-a-vis the independence of the colonists. And that is the key battle, isn't it? It is the key.
确实，当你去波士顿等地参观这些地方时，到处都是乔治三世对阵殖民地居民，但这实际上并不是这件事情的关键所在。关键在于议会的权威——这对英国人来说非常重要——议会权威与殖民地独立之间的关系。这才是关键的战斗，不是吗？这就是关键。
For if our trade may be taxed, why not our lands? Why not the produce of our lands and everything we possess or make use of, said the Boston merchants meeting in the 1760s. It's the basic principle that Parliament in London, which of course there are no members of Parliament sent across the Atlantic from the colonies, that they fundamentally reject the authority of Parliament. And up until the Seven Years' War and its immediate aftermath, while they may have theoretically also rejected the sovereignty of Parliament, in practical ways it had never really impinged
“如果我们的贸易可以被征税，为什么我们的土地不能？为什么我们的土地产品以及我们拥有或使用的所有东西不能？”1760年代开会的波士顿商人们如是说。这是一个基本原则：伦敦议会（殖民地当然没有派国会议员跨越大西洋）的权威，被他们从根本上拒绝了。在七年战争及其直接余波之前，虽然他们在理论上也可能拒绝过议会的统治权，但在实际操作中，它从未真正产生过影响。
upon them. But it did now, and they really, really, really didn't like it. So to take the first of these landmark acts, which is the Sugar Act, April 1764. The extraordinary thing about this is that this, so this actually cuts the tax on imported molasses. But the deal breaker is that they beef up the collection of it. So basically, for the first time, the tax is more than nominal. It's actually going to be properly enforced. It's the enforcement of it. It's the regulations and the bureaucracy and all that business.
强加在他们头上。但现在英国真的这么做了，而他们非常非常非常讨厌这一点。因此，首先来看这些具有里程碑意义的法案之一——《糖税法》，颁布于1764年4月。这件事最离谱的地方在于，它实际上削减了进口糖蜜的税率。但谈崩的关键在于，他们加大了对该税收的征收力度。所以基本上，这是有史以来第一次，税收不再只是名义上的了。它将真正得到严格执行。正是这种执行力度、规章制度、官僚作风以及这一整套东西，
That is what inflames the colonists, isn't it? That's right. And they threaten to send New England merchants to be tried in a vice-admiralty court in Nova Scotia without a trial, which is the way that customs violations are always dealt with in Britain. There's nothing innovative about this from the point of view of the British government, but from the point of view of the people in New England, this violates their ancient rights as Englishmen to always be tried by a jury.
彻底激怒了殖民地居民，对吧？没错。而且他们威胁要把新英格兰的商人送到新斯科舍省的副海事法院受审，并且没有陪审团，这正是英国处理海关违规行为一贯的方式。从英国政府的角度来看，这并没有什么创新之处，但从新英格兰人民的角度来看，这侵犯了他们作为英国人一向享有的、始终由陪审团审判的古老权利。
Even in a smuggling case, where as a long established precedent in England, if you're being tried for smuggling, what you don't want is a local jury to whom you've been supplying them the smuggled goods. So if you want to tackle smuggling, you have to have a proper vice-admiralty court without a jury. But to the New Englanders, this was outrageous because trial by jury was their basic right as Englishmen. And so they saw this as a deep violation of everything that they had come to assume was their rights and the way that they ran their own societies. Why mess with a system that was working was essentially the the colonial reaction
即便在走私案件中也是如此——在英国这是一个长期确立的先例，如果你因走私受审，你最不希望看到的就是由当地陪审团来审判，因为你可能一直都在向他们供应走私货。因此，如果你想打击走私，就必须设立一个没有陪审团的正规副海事法院。但对新英格兰人来说，这简直是无法无天，因为陪审团审判是他们作为英国人的基本权利。因此，他们认为这是对他们习以为常的一切权利以及他们管理自己社会方式的严重侵犯。殖民地居民的反应基本上是：一个运转良好的系统，为什么要瞎折腾？
and are they completely i mean presumably at various points the british are saying to them well obviously we're doing this because we need all these troops we need to pay for all these troops to beat the french to keep you safe from the indians to allow you to expand to do all these things is there no sense of any kind of conversation at both sides just not listening to each other or what that's such a good question dominic and i i kind of feel reading the history of all of this over this you know 20 year period of crisis that there really isn't a conversation you know these are two sides that are talking past one another almost from the beginning and certainly by the end.
我的意思是，难道英国人在各个节点没有完全在对他们说，很显然，我们这么做是因为我们需要所有这些军队，我们需要支付所有这些军队的费用来打败法国人，保护你们免受印第安人的伤害，让你们能够扩张，做所有这些事情？难道双方完全没有意识到有任何形式的对话，只是各说各话、互不理睬，还是怎么回事？多米尼克，这是一个太好的问题了。在阅读了所有这些历史——在这长达20年的危机时期——之后，我有一种感觉，那就是真的没有对话。你知道，这是两个从一开始、到最后几乎都一直在各说各话的阵营。
And I think that that's where the tragedy of this lies, I think. And the tragedy is that both sides basically are right. They are both right from their point of view. They're acting entirely reasonably from their point of view. I mean, overlaid on this becomes this sense of paranoia on both sides. But I think I think it's fair to say, especially on the American side, this increasing paranoia, which culminates in the Declaration of Independence with its series of really kind of paranoid, anxious denunciations of the king for things that the king clearly hadn't done in many cases. by 1776, Americans really believe all this stuff. They really believe they're being persecuted, that there is some plan to subjugate them, which then manifestly wasn't, but they genuinely believed it. So one of the answers to that is the introduction of the stamp tax, which is particularly notorious. And this is George Grenville again.
我想，悲剧就根源于此。我认为悲剧在于，双方基本上都是对的。从各自的立场来看，他们都是对的。从他们的角度来看，他们的行为完全合情合理。我的意思是，在这之上的，是双方逐渐滋生的一种偏执感。但我认为可以公平地说，特别是在美国这一侧，这种日益加剧的偏执最终在《独立宣言》中达到了顶峰——其中包含了一系列对国王真正带有偏执和焦虑色彩的谴责，而在许多情况下，国王显然并没有做那些事。到了1776年，美国人真的相信了所有这些东西。他们真的相信自己正在遭受迫害，相信存在某种奴役他们的计划，而这种计划当时显然并不存在，但他们却深信不疑。因此，对这一现象的解释之一，就是颁布了臭名昭著的印花税。这又是乔治·格伦维尔搞出来的。
And so colonists have to purchase special paper for legal documents. And it's seen as a kind of imposition. So it particularly affects lawyers and journalists who have banned people to annoy. Terrible thing to do. But Stamp Act, Tom, has been imposed in england since 1694 so it's not some terrible innovation but and and so grenville when he is introducing it
因此，殖民地居民必须为法律文件购买特殊的纸张。这被视为一种强加的负担。因此它特别影响了律师和记者，这帮人一向喜欢招人烦。这事干得真烂。但是汤姆，《印花税法》自1694年以来就一直在英国实行，所以它并不是什么可怕的创新，因此格伦维尔在推出它时，
is i mean he points out that people in america are being taxed about a tenth of what people in britain are being taxed and he he says the true way to relieve all is to make all contribute their proper share. So basically he's accusing the Americans of being freeloaders. Yes. Yes, that is. That is what he thinks. And there's a famous exchange in the House of Commons as well. Charles Townsend, he's later to come into the story
他的意思是，他指出美国人的税负大约是英国人的十分之一，他还说，减轻所有人负担的真正方法是让每个人都贡献出自己应得的份额。所以基本上，他是在指责美国人爱占便宜。是的。是的，确实如此。这就是他的想法。在下议院也有一场著名的辩论。查尔斯·唐森德——他稍后也会在故事中登场，
when he's Chancellor of the Exchequer, talks about these Americans, children planted by our care, nourished up by our indulgence until they're grown to a degree of strength and opulence and protected by our arms, would grudge to contribute their might to relieve us from the heavy weight of that burden which we lie under and the thing about that quote i've just given you compared to yours tom is that there is a tone of arrogance yeah which when that was read in the colonial press did not go down well and in fact it was that that that speech from of townsends in the house of commons was responded to by one of the the small number of people in the house of of Commons who right from the beginning were strong supporters of the colonial position. So there was a chap called, one of the famous ones was Edmund Burke, who of course was Irish. Another one was Isaac Barré, who was also Irish. And this may not be coincidence.
当时他是财政大臣——在谈到这些美国人时说：“这群由我们的关怀培育、由我们的纵容抚养长大，直到他们变得强大而富有，并受到我们的军队保护的孩子们，竟然吝于贡献出他们的微薄之力，来帮我们减轻压在我身上的沉重负担。”汤姆，我刚引用的这段话与你刚才的那段话相比，其中有一种傲慢的语调，是的，当这段话在殖民地的报纸上被宣读时，结果可想而知，并没有引起好感。事实上，下议院中极少数从一开始就坚定支持殖民地立场的人之一，对唐森德在下议院的这番演讲进行了反击。其中有一个人叫埃德蒙·伯克（其中一位大名鼎鼎的人物），他当然是个爱尔兰人。还有一个叫艾萨克·巴雷，他也是爱尔兰人。这或许并非巧合。
Barré, I think he was from a Huguenot family. And Barré, who knew the colonies, you know, unlike most people sitting in the House of Commons, he'd been there and he'd fought in the French and Indian War. And he responded to Townsend in this famous sort of sarcastic speech, you know, they planted by your care? No, your oppressions planted them in America. They nourished up by your indulgence. They grew by your neglect of them. They protected by your arms. They have nobly taken up arms in your defence, Barré said to the House of Commons. And this speech was then reprinted. He probably didn't sound like a comedy Irishman, actually. He probably didn't sound like that at all.
巴雷，我记得他来自一个胡格诺派家庭。对殖民地有所了解的巴雷（这与下议院大多数人不同），他去过那里，并且在英法印第安战争中战斗过。他用一种著名的讽刺口吻回击了唐森德，他说：“他们由你们的关怀培育？不，是你们的压迫在美洲孕育了他们。他们由你们的纵容抚养长大？他们是在你们的忽视中生长的。他们由你们的军队保护？他们为了保卫你们而英勇参战了。”巴雷对下议院这样说道。这段演讲随后被重新印刷。实际上，他听起来可能并不像一个滑稽的爱尔兰人。他听起来可能根本不是那样的。
But that speech was reprinted in the colonies. Later, when Edmund Burke gave his great speeches in defence of the colonists, they were all reprinted. I mean, Wilkes Bar in Pennsylvania is named after this guy. I mean, they loved these. I mean, naturally, you know, with these few people in the House of Commons who were saying what they wanted went down very well.
但那篇演讲在殖民地被重新印刷了。后来，当埃德蒙·伯克发表捍卫殖民地居民的伟大演讲时，这些演讲也全被重新印刷了。我的意思是，宾夕法尼亚州的威尔克斯巴雷就是以这家伙的名字命名的。我的意思是，他们太喜欢这些了。很自然地，下议院里这少数几个说出他们心声的人，当然大受欢迎。
But, Adam, just to continue, I'm sure provocatively to our American listeners, sticking up for Grenville. If there's the risk that the British Parliament's position of principle shades into arrogance, is there not also the sense in which the principles of American colonists shade into hypocrisy. So I'm thinking of Richard Henry Lee, who from Virginia become one of the founding fathers, signatory to the Declaration of Independence and so on. And his protest against the Stamp Act is that he gets his slaves to stage a kind of a reenactment of various protests that
但是，亚当，为了继续这个话题——我对我们的美国听众来说肯定具有挑衅意味——我们要为格伦维尔说句公道话。如果英国议会的原则立场有滑向傲慢的风险，难道美国殖民地居民的原则不也有滑向伪善的风险吗？我想到了理查德·亨利·李，他来自弗吉尼亚，后来成为国父之一、《独立宣言》的签署人等等。他对《印花税法》的抗议是，他让自己的奴隶在弗吉尼亚上演了一场对各种抗议活动的重演，
have been going on in the cities in Virginia against the Stamp Acts. And they parade effigies of Grenville, who is described as the infamous projector of American slavery. So this is being reenacted by slaves. And it then subsequently turns out that Lee himself had applied for the job of stamp distributor in Virginia. So there's all kinds of hypocrisies to be unpicked there.
这些抗议活动原本是为了抗议弗吉尼亚针对《印花税法》的城市抗议。他们游行展示了格伦维尔的肖像，格伦维尔被描述为“美洲奴役制度的罪恶策划者”。所以这一切是由奴隶们重新扮演的。而后来事实证明，李本人曾申请过弗吉尼亚印花税代售人的职务。所以其中有各种各样的虚伪之处需要去剥茧抽丝。
But what about the paranoia, Adam, that you mentioned? I mean, I'm just, when the Sugar Act and the Stamp Act come in, so in the mid-1760s, the American economy is in a bit of a mess, isn't it? The end of the war. Yeah, and that's really important, isn't it? The underlying problem here is the tightening of credit after the war,
但是亚当，你提到的偏执又是怎么回事呢？我的意思是，当《糖税法》和《印花税法》出台时——也就是在1760年代中期——美国经济陷入了一团糟，不是吗？战争刚刚结束。是的，这真的很重要，对吧？这里面潜在的问题是战后信贷收紧，
and it causes real economic distress. So that's obviously an element to the anxiety and the anguish and the sense that not only am I worse off than I was before, but the government's now interfering with me and getting me to fill in these forms and pay these new taxes. But the level of the paranoia, so the very famous speech by Patrick Henry in the House of Burgesses in Virginia, when he's talking about George III as a new Caesar or a new Charles I, and this sort of sense of what we would now call a kind of culture war element to it, and a sense of incipient tyranny. And the sort of, where does that come from? Is
这导致了真正的经济困境。因此，这显然是导致焦虑、痛苦以及一种感觉的因素之一：不仅我的处境比以前更糟了，而且政府现在还要干涉我，让我填写这些表格并支付这些新税。但这种偏执的程度——比如帕特里克·亨利在弗吉尼亚 burgesses 议会（下议院）发表的那场非常著名的演讲，他在演讲中将乔治三世比作新的凯撒或新的查理一世，以及这种我们现在称之为文化战争元素的感知，以及一种隐约的暴政感。这种感觉……这究竟是从哪里来的？
that to do with the religiosity of America? Is that because they're still trapped in a very 17th century King versus Parliament kind of mindset? I mean, why is it there? I mean, they've,'ve as you said they're two inches taller they've got all this space life is good why are they so why are they so stressed one answer is a sort of ideological one and there are two elements of that one is they're all great enlightenment thinkers and there's some basis to that you know some of them are reading locke some of them are reading montesquieu not very many of to that. Some of them are reading Locke. Some of them are reading Montesquieu. Not very many of them, obviously, but some of them are. John Adams certainly is. Thomas Jefferson is. The other reason, though, and I think perhaps a more important reason,
这与美国的宗教狂热有关吗？是因为他们仍然深陷于一种非常17世纪的“国王对决议会”的心态中吗？我的意思是，它为什么会存在？我的意思是，正如你所说，他们长高了两英寸，拥有了这么多的空间，生活很美好，为什么他们压力会这么大？其中一个答案是意识形态方面的，这里面有两个要素：一个是他们都是伟大的启蒙思想家，这有一定的依据，你知道的，其中一些人在读洛克，一些人在读孟德斯鸠。虽然显然不是很多人在读，但确实有些人读了。约翰·亚当斯绝对读过。托马斯·杰斐逊也读过。不过，另一个原因——我认为可能更重要的原因，
is the one that you just alluded to there, Dominic, which is the 17th century British Republican tradition. I think that's really where this come from, this deep St. Patrick Henry, who you just mentioned, of course, he's most, I mean, he was a great orator. Thomas Jefferson, who didn't like him, said he was a great orator, but Jefferson was a terrible speaker. But Patrick Henry's one of his most famous grades, of course, was give me liberty or give me death. And that deep of of the protection of individual rights and liberties which was as as englishman i mean this was this was there right from the from the 17th century english experience as you say and so adam one of the actually the kind of the main response in
就是你刚才提到的那个，多米尼克，也就是17世纪的英国共和主义传统。我认为这正是这一切的根源，这种根源极为深厚。你刚才提到的帕特里克·亨利，当然，他最——我的意思是，他是一位伟大的演说家。不喜欢他的托马斯·杰斐逊曾说他是个伟大的演说家，但杰斐逊自己是个糟糕的演讲者。不过帕特里克·亨利最著名的豪言壮语之一，当然就是“不自由，毋宁死”。正如你所说，这种对个人权利和自由保护的坚定信念——作为英国人，这从17世纪的英国经历开始就一直存在。所以亚当，在
america to these um impositions by from london is the state boycotts of British goods. And the really famous example of that is that they refused to import British clothing and the American women get out their spinning wheels and start making rough homespun and all that kind of thing. And that presumably is something in New England that would hark back to the idea of the Puritan hussif, godly housekeeper and so on. They're able to do that by drawing on those traditions.
美国对伦敦这些强加的税收措施的主要回应之一，就是对英国商品的州际抵制。其中一个非常著名的例子是，他们拒绝进口英国服饰，美国的女性们纷纷拿出纺织车，开始制作粗糙的土布等等。在新英格兰，这大概会让人回想起清教徒家庭主妇、虔诚管家等传统。她们能够做到这一点，正是借助了这些传统。
Yes, I think Benjamin Franklin, when he's testifying to Parliament, says, and we don't eat lamb anymore. Because the little lambs are all growing fluffy in the field so we can use their fleeces to turn into wool. So take that, Parliament. Yes, and so this craze for homespun and people turning up to the Virginia House of Burgesses and not wearing proper wigs. That is shocking behaviour. And it's not a massive success in many ways, the non-importation movement, but it's really interesting because it's one of the first examples of an attempt to use consumer boycotts to affect political action. It's always leaky.
是的，我想本杰明·富兰克林在向议会作证时曾说：“我们不再吃羊肉了。”因为小羊们都在田野里长得毛茸茸的，这样我们就可以用它们的羊毛来纺织成毛料了。所以，议会，接着吧！是的，因此这种土布狂热，以及人们穿着不戴得体假发的便服出现在弗吉尼亚议会大院里，这简直是令人发指的行为。从许多方面来看，不合作运动并不是一次巨大的成功，但它非常有趣，因为它是利用消费者抵制行动来影响政治行动的最早例证之一。它总是漏洞百出。
There are some very kind of performative gestures. You know, the students at Yale stop importing French wine. The students at Harvard don't drink tea. I mean, there's this kind of thing goes on. But what it's telling us, of course, is how far the protests against the Sugar Acts and the Stamp Acts that we're talking about seeped into colonial society and involved women, of course, who were the principal consumers in most households in charge of the household budget. But there are violent protests as well, aren't there?
有一些非常具有表演性质的姿态。你知道的，耶鲁大学的学生停止进口法国葡萄酒。哈佛大学的学生不喝茶。诸如此类的事情一直在发生。但当然，这告诉我们的是，我们所谈论的针对《糖税法》和《印花税法》的抗议活动，已经深入到殖民地社会的什么程度，并且自然而然地卷入了女性——她们是大多数家庭中负责家庭预算的主要消费者。但也有暴力抗议，对吧？
So there's a famous incident on the 14th of August, 1765, when a mob attacks this guy, Andrew Oliver, who's the stamp distributor from Massachusetts. And after that point, I mean, they basically intimidate the stamp distributors. So there's a violence there. I mean, this is 11 years before the Declaration of Independence. And is that violence new or violence there. I mean, this is 11 years before the Declaration of Independence. And is that violence new? Or was that, I mean, obviously, this is the age of mobs in England and London. So is this just par for the course, just standard political kind of stuff?
所以有一个著名的事件发生在1765年8月14日，当时暴民袭击了来自马萨诸塞州的印花税代售人安德鲁·奥利弗。在那之后，我的意思是，他们基本上恐吓了印花税代售人。所以这里面存在暴力。我的意思是，这发生在《独立宣言》发表的11年前。这种暴力是新鲜事吗？还是说，我的意思是，很显然，这是英国和伦敦暴民横行的时代，所以这只是司空见惯的事，只是一种标准的政治行为？
In fairness, I think this is par for the course. I mean, if you want to make a political point, you gather a mob. I don't think there's anything that happens in the colonies, there's anything like on the scale of the gordon riots in in london a few years after the incident that you're talking about and you mobs which weren't regarded as unrestrained but were regarded as men of property and standing making a political point through force was was part of the english constitution and when they when they i mean you you're right about andrew oliver the other incident that happens around the same time is the mob goes to the house of Thomas Hutchison, who's I think the acting governor of Massachusetts Bay Colony at that time, and carefully dismantle his house. But I mean, carefully, you know, they put up ladders and they pull the tiles off the
公平地说，我认为这只是司空见惯。我的意思是，如果你想表达一个政治观点，你就会聚拢一群暴民。我认为殖民地发生的事情，其规模根本无法与你所谈论的事件几年后伦敦发生的戈登暴动相提并论。而且，那些暴民并不被视为不受约束的乌合之众，而是被视为有产者和名流通过武力表达政治观点的一部分——这是英国宪法的一部分。当他们——我的意思是，你对安德鲁·奥利弗的看法是对的，几乎同时发生的另一件事是，暴民去了托马斯·哈钦森的家（当时他好像是马萨诸塞湾殖民地的代理总督），并仔细地拆卸了他的房子。但我的意思是，非常仔细地，你知道的，他们架起梯子，把屋顶的瓦片一块块拆下来，
roof and they take the paintings out and put them on a bonfire. But it's not just, they're not just firebombing it. I mean, it's a careful disassembly. And it does work, doesn't it, because the Stamp Act gets repealed? It worked brilliantly. It is impossible to implement the Stamp Act in the colonies, and Parliament repeals it. Unfortunately, perhaps from the point of view of dealing with this colonial rebellion, they at the same time pass a declaratory act saying, well, although we've repealed the Stamp Act, we nevertheless reserve the right to pass such a thing again.
把画作搬出来堆在篝火上。但这不仅仅是，他们不只是纵火轰炸。我的意思是，这是一次仔细的拆解。而且它确实奏效了，不是吗？因为《印花税法》被废除了。它取得了辉煌的成功。在殖民地推行《印花税法》是不可能的，于是议会将其废除了。不幸的是，从应对这场殖民地叛乱的角度来看，他们同时通过了一项《宣示法》，声称：“好吧，尽管我们废除了《印花税法》，但我们依然保留了再次通过此类法案的权力。”
We're not resiling from the principle of parliamentary sovereignty. And that's a bit of a poke to the Americans that was perhaps unnecessary. And the Townshend Act, so all the things regulating tea and molasses and all that, they are still in place? So the Townshend duties come in a little bit later. So that's in 1767 in a new ministry. So there's a renewed effort then in 1767 after a couple of quieter years because the same problems still exist. The same revenue challenges still face the British government in London.
我们并没有背离议会至上的原则。这有点像对美国人的一种挑衅，或许是没有必要的。《唐森德法案》——所有那些监管茶叶、糖蜜等等的法案——仍然有效吗？所以唐森德关税稍后才出台。那是1767年在一个新的内阁任内。所以在经历了几年比较安静的时期后，1767年又重新展开了努力，因为同样的问题依然存在。伦敦的英国政府依然面临着同样的税收挑战。
So there's a new attempt then not to impose an internal tax like the stamp duties, which would have affected transactions in everyday life and newspapers and playing cards and all this kind of thing, but to tax imports and exports in a way that was felt to be much better established with much stronger precedent. But the towns and duties also then generated strong colonial resistance. So in the face of this kind of these increasing tensions, there's a request from customs agents in Boston for military assistance. And two army regiments arrive in Boston in early October 1768. And intriguingly, they are commanded by someone called William Dalrymple, who I gather is an ancestor of the William Dalrymple. Yes, he presents our sister podcast Empire. So there he is upholding the British Empire.
因此，当时有了一种新的尝试：不再强加像印花税那样会影响日常生活交易、报纸和扑克牌等方方面面的内部税，而是以一种被认为更加成熟、拥有更强先例支持的方式来对进出口征税。但唐森德关税随后也引发了强烈的殖民地抵抗。因此，面对这种日益加剧的紧张局势，波士顿的海关官员要求提供军事援助。1768年10月初，两个陆军团抵达波士顿。有趣的是，他们的指挥官是一个叫威廉·达尔林普尔的人，据我所知，他似乎是那个威廉·达尔林普尔的祖先。是的，他主持了我们的姊妹播客《大英帝国》。所以，他就站在那里维护大英帝国。
And it all basically kicks off. So, Adam, Massachusetts. What is it specifically, by the way, before we get into the so-called Boston Massacre? What is it specifically about Boston and about Massachusetts that makes it so incendiary? Because in Britain, everybody basically from this point on would start saying, listen, the colonies are absolutely fine. It's just that Boston is full of a load of nutters. And if we can just shut down Boston, then we'll probably be able to shut all this whole business down.
然后一切基本上就爆发了。所以，亚当，马萨诸塞州。在我们在深入讨论所谓的波士顿惨案之前，具体是什么原因——顺便问一下——使得波士顿和马萨诸塞州如此具有煽动性？因为在英国，从这个时刻开始，基本上所有人都会开始说：“听着，殖民地完全没问题。只是波士顿住满了疯子。如果我们能把波士顿搞定，那我们可能就能把这整个事情都搞定了。”
So is there something specific either to Boston or to Massachusetts or indeed to New England? Well, part of it is because of the economic downturn after the war and that Boston merchants are really feeling the pinch and that they are heavily involved in smuggling imported goods without paying the duties that they're supposed to be paying. So Boston is more particularly affected than other port cities. But it's also perhaps to do with the political culture of Massachusetts and a very, very strongly ingrained sense of self-governance and a very articulate political leadership and a press that is quick and articulate and a tradition of mobs in Boston as well, taking to the streets to make political points. And all of those things together probably push Boston to the fore. But the British perspective that this is only a Boston and
所以，是波士顿、马萨诸塞州还是整个新英格兰有什么特殊之处吗？部分原因在于战后的经济低迷，波士顿商人们真正感到了压力，他们深度参与了走私进口货物而无需支付本应缴纳的关税的活动。因此，波士顿比其他港口城市受到的影响更明显。但这可能也与马萨诸塞州的政治文化有关，这里有一种非常非常根深蒂固的自治意识、极具表达力的政治领导层、反应敏捷且能言善辩的媒体，以及波士顿走上街头表达政治观点的暴民传统。所有这些因素结合在一起，大概把波士顿推向了风口浪尖。但英国人认为这只是波士顿和
Massachusetts problem is, of course, wrong and is gradually proven to be wrong. It's incredible how long it takes people in London to realise that. I mean, even into the war, one of the key military strategies is this attempt to isolate Boston in the hope that that will subdue the rebellion and it doesn't work. So there are troops pouring in. I mean, these troops, as Tom said, these two regiments that have actually been transferred from Ireland, I think, the William Doubt-Rimple's regiments, they've arrived in Boston in the autumn of 17 1768 and anybody who's ever written about or read about a phenomenon where you have troops stationed in a city where they are effectively
马萨诸塞州的问题的观点，当然是错误的，并且逐渐被证明是错误的。伦敦人花了这么长时间才意识到这一点，真是不可思议。我的意思是，甚至到了战争期间，核心的军事战略之一依然是试图孤立波士顿，希望以此来平息叛乱，但这并不起作用。因此，军队源源不断地涌入。我的意思是，正如汤姆所说，这些军队——这些实际上是从爱尔兰调来的两个团，我想就是威廉·达尔林普尔的团——在1768年秋天抵达了波士顿。任何写过或读过这种现象的人都知道，当你在一座城市里驻扎了一支实际上属于
alien knows at some point there is going to be a flashpoint and actually in a way it's surprising it takes so long so it's not until the beginning of 1770 now, no doubt like me, you have been to the Boston Freedom Trail. I have. And you've seen the terrible, you know, the very moving commemorations of the Boston Massacre, this scar in the history of our species, when the British were conceived to have behaved absolutely disgracefully. And yet, when I read about what actually happened in the so-called Boston Massacre, it seems like our brave boys were a little bit hard done by.
知道在某个时候肯定会发生冲突爆发点，而且在某种程度上，花了这么长时间才发生其实令人惊讶。所以直到1770年初。毫无疑问，你们和我一样，都去过波士顿自由之路（Boston Freedom Trail）。我去过。你一定看过那些令人痛心、非常感人的对波士顿惨案的纪念，这是我们人类历史上的一道伤疤，当时人们认为英国人的表现极其可耻。然而，当我读到关于所谓波士顿惨案实际发生经过的记载时，我觉得我们勇敢的小伙子们有点委屈。
Do you want to tell the listeners the true story? Well, there were a small number of British troops who ended up confronting several hundred local inhabitants of the town. There'd been various small episodes that had led up to this in the preceding days and words had been bandied around and clearly the relations between the Redcoats, the regular troops and townspeople had not been great, not least because the British troops were underpaid and were needing to find jobs here and there.
你想把真实的故事告诉听众吗？嗯，有一小撮英国军队最终与该镇数百名当地居民对峙。在此之前的几天里，曾发生过各种小插故，导致了这一局面的发生，双方言语交锋，显然红衫军（正规军）与镇民之间的关系一直不太好，尤其是因为英国士兵薪水过低，需要在各处找工作。
And so they were actually kind of dependent on the townspeople in some ways and didn't like that dependent relationship. It was creating constant friction. And stones were chucked. And the accounts always say snowballs were chucked, which never really sounds that bad. They really were chucking snowballs.
所以他们在某种程度上其实有点依赖镇民，又不喜欢这种依赖关系。这造成了持续的摩擦。而且有人扔了石头。账目记录总是说有人扔了雪球，这听起来从来没有那么糟糕。他们确实在扔雪球。
Bricks inside. So I noticed that the American accounts very heavily emphasized the snowballs and the British accounts very heavily emphasized stones and cudgels. Yes. Oyster shells, don't they? Yes. Oyster shells. I think the roads were paved with oyster shells. So they were a very easily available missile to grab up.
里面还有砖块。所以我注意到，美洲方面的记录极力强调雪球，而英国方面的记录则极力强调石头和大棒。是的。还有牡蛎壳，对吧？是的。牡蛎壳。我想路面是用牡蛎壳铺成的。所以它们是非常容易随手抓到的投掷物。
But as you say, Dominic, this is a story that we've seen many, many times. In fact, it happens multiple times in American cities well into the 21st century that whenever you get armed forces confronting unarmed protesters, stuff happens. And what happens here was that five bostonians were shot by british troops the british account is that the that they small number of troops massively outnumbered were um forced against literally forced against a wall and and had to shoot in self-defense um that was the british. And the American account is the opposite, right? So Paul Revere, is it Paul Revere who's the silversmith who does this famous, famous engraving?
但正如你所说，多米尼克，这是我们见过很多很多次的场景。事实上，在美洲城市里，这种事在进入21世纪后也多次发生：每当武装部队与非武装抗议者对峙时，事情就会发生。这里发生的事情是，五名波士顿人被英国军队开枪打死。英国方面的说法是，那一小撮兵力悬殊的军队被……字面意义上被逼到墙角，不得不进行正当防卫开枪。这就是英国的说法。而美洲方面的说法则相反，对吧？所以保罗·里维尔，就是那个制作了这幅非常著名的版画的银匠保罗·里维尔吗？
Engraving, yes. Of kind of a line of soldiers mercilessly shooting into these women and children or whatever they are. But the intriguing detail is that actually, and this is omitted from Paul Revere's illustration of it, is that the leader of the Bostonian freedom fighters or mob or whatever you want to call them is a towering dock worker called Crispus Attucks
版画，是的。描绘了一排士兵无情地向这些妇女和儿童或不管他们是什么人开枪的场景。但其中一个耐人寻味的细节其实是——而保罗·里维尔的插图里遗漏了这一点——波士顿自由斗士或暴民（随便你怎么称呼他们）的领袖是一个身材高大的码头工人，名叫克里斯帕斯·阿塔克斯（Crispus Attucks），
who is half black, half Native American. And so he gets omitted from the narrative. Yeah. An interesting aftermath of the trial is that John Adams, who we've already mentioned in this discussion, a leader of colonial resistance, who's a lawyer, defends the British soldiers in court. And he does so in order to make the point that we in Boston are not lawless mobs. We do things by due process. And even in
他具有一半黑人血统和一半美洲原住民血统。因此，他被从叙事中遗漏了。是的。审判的一个有趣余波是，我们在这次讨论中已经提到过的殖民地抵抗领袖、律师约翰·亚当斯（John Adams），在法庭上为英国士兵进行了辩护。他这样做的目的是为了表明：我们波士顿人不是无法无天的暴民。我们按正当程序办事。甚至在
Boston, in this moment in 1770, British soldiers can get a fair trial. And one of his key lines of defence, Tom, is that he defends the soldiers by saying they were facing a motley rabble of saucy boys, Negroes and mulattoes, Irish teagues and outlandish jacktars. And he puts a lot of the blame specifically on Crispus Attucks, a formerly enslaved man by saying his very look was enough to terrify any person so effectively Adams is
波士顿、在1770年这个时刻，英国士兵也能得到公正的审判。而汤姆，他主要的辩护策略之一，就是通过声称这些士兵面对的是“一群由厚颜无耻的男孩、黑人和混血儿、爱尔兰乡巴佬以及外省水手组成的乌合之众”来为士兵辩护。他将很大一部分责任直接归咎于克里斯帕斯·阿塔克斯（一个曾经被奴役的人），声称他“仅仅是看一眼就足以吓坏任何人”。因此，亚当实际上是在
saying look face with that lot and especially that guy you know who can blame the British troops for panicking and so what happens how do they get off yeah they do get off Tom yeah don't they Adam yeah two of them manslaughter and they get off? Yeah, they do get off, Tom. Don't they, Adam? Yeah. Two of them manslaughter and they get branded on their thumbs and the rest are not guilty. Yeah. That's right. Yes, they get branded on their thumbs. Yes.
说：“看呐，面对这样一群人，尤其是那个家伙，谁能责怪英国士兵惊慌失措呢？”那么结果如何？他们被无罪释放了吗？是的，他们确实被无罪释放了，汤姆。不是吗，亚当？是的。其中两人被判过失杀人罪，并在拇指上被打上烙印，其余人无罪。是的。就是这样。是的，他们在拇指上被烙印。
So at that point, so we're 1770, that's still six years before the Declaration of Independence. At that point, are we already in a spiral that is going to lead to outright conflict and American independence? Or, you know, is there, I mean, as we said, there's mob violence all the time. There are lots of dust-ups and things on the streets of London. Actually, could this have just been a footnote in history if things in the next six years had gone differently, Adam? I think the second.
所以，到了那个时候——我们正处于1770年，距离《独立宣言》还有整整六年。在那个时候，我们是否已经陷入了一场将不可避免地导致全面冲突和美国独立的螺旋？还是说，我的意思是，正如我们所说，暴力暴动无时无刻不在发生，伦敦街头也有大量的冲突和摩擦。事实上，如果在接下来的六年里事情有不同的走向，这本来会只是历史上的一个脚注吗，亚当？我认为是后者。
I don't think that American independence was unstoppable in 1770. I think this could have been a footnote. I think there are an awful lot. We'd have to imagine, and we can talk about this in future episodes, we'd have to do an awful lot of intellectual work to imagine some quite significantly different things would have to have happened between 1770 and 1776. But I don't think there was anything inevitable about American independence at this
我不认为1770年的美国独立是不可阻挡的。我认为这本可以只是一个脚注。我认为有非常多的……我们必须想象——我们可以在以后的节目中讨论这一点——我们必须做大量的思想工作来设想，在1770年到1776年之间，必须发生一些非常显著的不同事情。但我认为在这一点上，美国独立并没有任何不可避免性，尤其是对于殖民地的抗议者来说更是如此。我的意思是，如果你在1770年对约翰·亚当斯说：“你们正走在通往独立的道路上吗？”他会感到震惊。你觉得华盛顿和富兰克林也是如此吗？是的，我的意思是，华盛顿当时只是在追求他自己的。我的意思是，直到局势发展到非常后期，华盛顿才真正卷入这场斗争。直到1775年他成为大陆会议成员时，华盛顿——我们其实并不真正知道华盛顿当时在想什么。大概他对……我有广泛的同情，我的意思是，我们确实多少知道，因为他写过信件之类东西。但我的意思是，他当时肯定不是叛乱的领袖。
point, not least in the minds of the colonial protesters. I mean, if you just said to John Adams in 1770, are you on the road to independence? He would have been appalled. And the same of Washington and Franklin, do you think? Yeah, I mean, Washington at this point was just pursuing his own. I mean, Washington really wasn't engaged in this fight at all up until very late in the game. It wasn't really until 1775 when he became a member of the Continental Congress that Washington, we don't really know what Washington was thinking. Presumably he had broad sympathy with the, I mean, we do kind of know because he wrote letters and things. But I mean, he certainly wasn't the leader of the rebellion at this point.
但不是，这些人在当时仍然在为他们作为英国人的权利而战。很有可能，出于我们在本期节目中所讨论的原因，他们这样做是基于对英国宪法本质（即其实际本质）的根本误解，以至于他们永远无法如愿以偿。但在当时，他们想要的是在大英帝国内部实现一种实际意义上的自治独立，同时保持对他们继续崇敬的国王的效忠。当然，波士顿的这起事件就发生在国王街。
But no, these people, the colonists at this point were fighting for their rights as Englishmen still. And it may well be for the reasons that we've been talking about in this episode, that they were doing so on the basis of such a fundamental misunderstanding of the nature, the actual nature of the British constitution, that they were never going to get their way. But at this point, what they wanted was to have independence of a practical kind of self-governance within the British empire, maintaining their allegiance to the king, who they continued to revere. This episode, of course, in Boston took place on King Street. Yeah. So what might have been? And I think on that note, we will end our kind of curtain raiser, our scene setter. And in the next episode, we will be looking at the road to open war
所以，历史可能会是怎样呢？我想借此机会，我们将结束我们的开场白、我们的背景铺垫。在下一期节目中，我们将探讨通往全面战争、
to the Declaration of Independence and so on. That's right. That episode is on Thursday, Tom. It is on Thursday. Yes. The Tea Party, the Boston Tea Party. What a shocking moment. The battles of Lexington and Concord, on that's right that episode is on thursday tom it is on thursday yes the tea party the boston tea party what a shocking moment the battles of lexington and concord bunker hill heard around the world all that exactly george iii proclaiming american rebellion and the road to the full-scale
通往《独立宣言》等等的道路。没错。那一期节目是在周四播出，汤姆。确实是在周四。是的。茶党，波士顿倾茶事件。多么令人震惊的时刻。列克星敦和康科德的战役——没错，那一期节目是在周四播出，汤姆。确实是在周四。是的。茶党，波士顿倾茶事件。多么令人震惊的时刻。列克星敦和康科德的战役、邦克山、响彻世界的枪声，所有这些，确切地说，还有乔治三世宣告美国叛乱，以及通往全面
war now of course that will be on thursday if you're a member of the rest is history club tom what's the good news if you're a member of the Restless History Club? Well, the good news is that the commercial spirit of the British Empire in the 18th century carries on into the 21st. And you can sign up for the Restless History Club and hear not just the next episode, but the next three episodes all in one spectacular game. And if you're American, I know what's on your mind. It is tax free. There is no stamp. There is no, there is no stamp. There is no toll to pay.
战争的道路。现在，当然，如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，那一期节目将在周四播出。汤姆，如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，有什么好消息吗？嗯，好消息是，18世纪大英帝国的商业精神一直延续到了21世纪。你可以注册加入“历史的其余部分”俱乐部，不仅能收听下一期节目，还能一口气连听接下来的三期精彩节目。如果你是美国人，我知道你心里在想什么：它是免税的。没有印花税。没有，没有印花税。没有要缴纳的通行费。
It's remarkably good value. And that should make you reflect upon your conduct. That bombshell Adam, we'll welcome you back on Thursday for the next episode. Thank you so much as always. And we'll see you all next time. Bye. Bye.
这真是物超所值。这应该让你反思一下自己的行为了。伴随着这个重磅炸弹，亚当，我们欢迎你在周四回来收听下一期节目。一如既往地非常感谢你。我们下期节目再见。再见。再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. next time bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听“历史的其余部分”。想要收听额外节目、提前收听和免广告收听，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，向您揭示这一切的运作方式。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想要免广告收听、额外节目以及提前获得现场门票，现在本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。